let's go back to a story we tried to
bring you uh earlier and that's those
air strikes on the ukrainian capital
let's join charles stratford our
correspondent who's following events for
us in the capital uh charles good to
have you back with us uh just give us an
update on what we know about these
strikes
well you join us here so outside one of
the strike sites this is a civilian
residential building that we understood
stand
was hit by one of two missiles the other
one landing very close to here
those missiles two of four
that
is being reported were cruise missiles
that landed
in kiev in the early hours of this
morning
emergency services here we understand
are still trying to search for bodies
people that they understand are trapped
inside at least one woman
her daughter was taken away in an
ambulance
uh in the last hour or so as was her
husband severely injured the husband's
not actually showing any signs of life
um you can see the the level of
devastation the power of these these
cruise missiles that hit
interestingly the building was just off
camera
to to my left here to my right sorry was
also hit
about a month ago so
this is not the first time this
area has been hit we also understand
there is another strike site up the road
we're being told a kindergarten
um or very close to a kindergarten
what's been described as a huge crater
in the ground as i say about 6 30 this
morning we were woken up at our hotel um
by what sounded we initially thought
as a jet fighter
transpires that these were cruise
missiles now as i say these are the
first hits
on the on the ukrainian capital for
about a month now
we had the mayor here earlier on as you
can imagine condemning these attacks
he's saying that this was another
example
of russian
atrocities
and yet again highlighting that there
seems to be nowhere
throughout this country that the
russians cannot hit but uh yeah very
worrying scenes here as i say the search
goes on for this woman believed still to
be trapped inside this building thanks
very much for the update charles
trapford there for us in keeve